zone Europe sur sensation
[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans ce
nouveau numéro de zone Europe sur Radio
sensation et sur TV 78 un numéro un peu
particulier aujourd'hui puisque nous
sommes sur l'île de Rhodes en Grèce la
Grèce un pays d'un peu plus de 10
millions d'habitants elle est membre de
l'Union européenne depuis le 1er janvier
1981 elle est membre de la zone euro
depuis le 1er janvier 2001 pendant 5
jours si délégation venue de toute
l'Europe Allemagne Pays-Bas France Suède
Pologne et Grèce se retrouvent ici à
Rhodes pour une série d'ateliers et de
visites autour du pacte vert européen et
des opportunités pour les zones rurales
c'est le projet JIRA initiative verte
dans les zones rurales et nous allons
tenter d'en savoir un petit peu plus au
cours de cette émission
[Musique]
nous avons tout de suite rendez-vous à
la Chambre de commerce et d'industrie
c'est là-bas que le coup d'envoi du
séminaire est donné avec toutes les
délégations Michael kaouclisme bonjour
vous êtes le président de la Maison de
l'Europe de Rhodes est-ce que déjà pour
commencer vous pourriez nous décrire
nous présenter cette île et cette ville
de Rhodes ici en Grèce
la ville a été fondée en 408 avant
Jésus-Christ après la réunification des
anciens États de la période grecque
l'état de Rhodes a commencé à l'or à
grandir jusqu'à devenir un lieu
privilégié pour les sciences et les arts
pendant la période romane et il est Nick
vous connaissez sûrement quelques
sculptures locales comme la victoire de
Samos race
le Colosse de Rhodes la machine
d'Anticythère
dans cette ville qui a été donné le
lancement le coup d'envoi du projet JIRA
initiative verte dans les zones rurales
quelles sont les objectifs de ce projet
le projet Gira pour objectif de
recueillir les bonnes pratiques en
Europe parmi les six pays participants
JIRA ce sont les initiales de Green
initiative in rural areas quand nous
évoquons les zones rurales nous
aimerions aussi que les zones insulaires
et les parties les plus isolées soient
comprise dans ce projet les 6 pays
participant la Grèce avec Rhodes la
France l'Allemagne la Suède la Pologne
et les Pays-Bas organiseront des
réunions localement afin de recueillir
des bonnes pratiques locales et ce en
accord avec le pacte vert pour l'Europe
et les objectifs du développement
durable
donc de Rhodes se situe à l'est au
sud-est de la mer Égée quelques dizaines
de kilomètres des côtes Turcs c'est la
plus grande île du dos des cannaise en
Grèce on y trouve près de 120 000
habitants et ici les initiatives en
faveur de l'environnement ne manquent
pas est-ce que vous pouvez nous en
présenter quelques-unes
plus grande île grecque comme vous
l'avez mentionné il fait partie de
l'archipel Dodécanèse dont plus de 18
îles sont habitées avec entre un
habitant et 120 000 habitants comme ici
à Rhodes notre zone est assez innovante
et pionnière dans l'adaptation de
nouvelles technologies et de technologie
écologiques à petit échelle chacune est
un petit monde en soit un petit état à
part tout doit être produit de manière
locale et cela dépend des ressources
propres nous avons de bons exemples à
Rhodes liés à l'écomobilité et d'autres
pratiques que nous découvrirons plus
tard ici mais aussi à stipaller ou à
chalki ces territoires essayent
d'innover de créer des pratiques qui
seront appliquées ensuite à grande
échelle
d'avoir été avec nous je rappelle que
vous êtes le président de la Maison de
l'Europe de Rhodes
[Musique]
arrêtons-nous maintenant à kaminari un
petit village situé à une trentaine de
kilomètres au sud de Rhodes sur cette
île 80% des habitants dépendent du
tourisme il faut donc à la fois attirer
de nouveaux visiteurs mais aussi
protéger l'environnement ici a été
recréé un ancien village traditionnel
grec sorte de musée à ciel ouvert où
l'on peut venir découvrir les traditions
locales
je suis l'un des responsables de ce
village traditionnel l'idée derrière ce
lieu est de créer une réplique d'un
ancien village comme ceux qui existaient
dans cette zone à Rhodes celui-ci
présente la culture traditionnelle
l'éthique et l'histoire de novillages
gastron cela comprend notre gastronomie
locale les traditions et les métiers qui
existaient ici par le passé
tout cela combiné bien sûr avec la
nature et de cette zone qui est très
très ancienne
pour l'environnement nous valorisons les
plantes la faune et la flore locale de
la région
par exemple l'origan le teint les
orchidées poussent ici à Rhodes
le tourisme et l'environnement sont
selon moi bien interconnectés à mon avis
rode soutiendra et inclura les questions
environnementales en ce qui concerne le
tourisme
bien évidemment les plages et le soleil
seront toujours présents ici mais nous
avons également des paysages
exceptionnels à visiter forêt rivière et
débarrages dans cette partie de l'île
[Musique]
découvrons une nouvelle initiative ici
sur l'île de Rhodes dans le parc juste à
côté des sources qualita les hôtels mais
aussi les écoles sont mis à contribution
pour nettoyer les lieux
et je suis le responsable de la société
à impact social yatafissy en français
nature commune
nous sommes actuellement dans un parc un
parc que nous souhaitons transformer en
lieu de sensibilisation à
l'environnement
et ce very Burton pour nous il est très
important de fournir un espace aux
étudiants où ils peuvent comprendre la
nature
comment on crée de la vie à partir de
zéro
jusqu'à obtenir une vie que tu peux
toucher sentir écouter respirer
tout dans la nature respire
donc c'est pour cela qu'il est essentiel
d'expliquer aux jeunes aux filles aux
garçons
[Musique]
la connexion qui existe entre eux-mêmes
et la nature donc ici nous agissons en
tant que société à impact social
dans un projet en collaboration avec les
propriétaires des hôtels ah oui nous
invitons les personnes aux gens dans ces
hôtels
à venir travailler ici de manière
bénévole
donc pour nettoyer et préserver le parc
afin de le rendre étudiable
les étudiants viennent ensuite apprendre
la nature
donc de cette manière nous combinons
tous risques et population locale
industrie du tourisme et environnement
à la fin ce projet s'étalera sur un parc
de cent mille mètres carrés
non seulement pour la population locale
mais également pour tous les Européens
qui veulent venir et apprendre sur la
nature chez nous
en Europe
[Musique]
les sources de kalithéâ sont réputées
depuis l'Antiquité elles ont ensuite été
reconstruites en 1929 lors de
l'occupation italienne puis restaurer en
1999 elle constitue un très bel exemple
d'intégration de l'architecture en plein
milieu naturel je suis Michael
kabuchliss président de la Maison de
l'Europe à Rhodes et haute de la réunion
de l'initiative grecque green initiative
une rurale un projet financé par Erasmus
et par la Commission européenne
nous sommes au bain de qualité à une
attraction culturelle et une des
principales enclaves de Rhodes c'est une
zone de spa dans laquelle les visiteurs
boivent de l'eau spéciale que nous
retrouvons uniquement ici pour traiter
des maladies du Rhin ou autre une
pratique notamment popularisée lors de
l'occupation italienne vers 1829
ont été restaurés en 2009 et ouverts
ensuite au public depuis c'est l'une des
attractions les plus populaires et mieux
préservées de Rhodes cet endroit offre
de beaux paysages naturels à côté de la
mer et avec plein de rochers un espace
culturel insolite utilisé comme lieu de
célébration des cérémonies pour des
mariages ou de grands événements pour la
population locale mais aussi un grand
jardin botanique avec des plantes et des
épices typiques de l'île de Rhodes
nous proposons ce projet ici car c'est
un bel exemple de coopération entre
citoyens et municipalité en Grèce qui
allie
héritage culturel et développement
durable c'est une manière de
sensibiliser sur la question de
l'environnement en utilisant des
paysages connus à l'international
[Musique]
je me trouve actuellement dans la vallée
des papillons à une dizaine de
kilomètres de l'aéroport de Rhodes ici
au mois de juin on peut trouver des
espèces très rares de papillons présents
dans très peu d'endroits sur terre cela
fait de cette vallée un lieu
incontournable de la biodiversité de
l'île de Rhodes
j'ai été l'une des présidentes
fondatrices de la Maison de l'Europe de
Rhodes
nous sommes ici dans la vallée des
papillons situés dans la partie nord de
Rhodes
où chaque été en juin des millions de
papillons viennent de beaucoup
d'endroits pour y vivre et passer
l'époque estivale entre juin et
septembre
c'est à dire pendant la période adulte
de leur vie
c'est papillon dont la durée de vie et
de seulement un an change et se
métamorphose quatre fois mais
flying période
se déroulent pendant l'été et la période
des œufs ce produit à la fin de l'été
comme c'est le cas en ce moment fin
septembre
pendant l'hiver et ce jusqu'au mois de
mars nous sommes dans la période de
métamorphose de la chenille chez hunters
durant cette période le papillon habite
dans les pins
sous les arbres pour y passer la période
de cocon
il se transforme en insecte volant le
papillon que nous connaissons
ce qui est particulier ici c'est la
concentration très élevée de papillons
ces milliards de papillons ça n'existe
carotte ils viennent habite et passent
l'été dans cet espace ce phénomène a été
étudié par beaucoup d'entomologistes
dans cette profonde vallée elle est
suffisamment sombre
les grands arbres pour avoir de l'ombre
des températures basses en été sont
d'autres conditions favorables pour les
papillons
nous sommes dans le meilleur
environnement pour qu'ils vivent leur
période d'adultes
[Musique]
on va faire une pause gourmande à
présent dans un Europe vous le savez on
aime vous faire voyager dans la sienne
et ici en Grèce on mange du tassiti de
la feta mais nous on va vous faire
découvrir une autre recette
traditionnelle dans les cuisines du
restaurant Tamar yassa
bonjour je suis Nico Siri je suis le
propriétaire du restaurant Tamar yassa
ce beau lieu au milieu de la ville de
Rhodes et aujourd'hui nous allons
préparer une recette locale appelée
pittarudis
de Rhodes
et végétarienne mais très savoureuse
surface
nous devons couper les courgettes et les
émincés jusqu'à obtenir des fines
tranches ensuite on laisse reposer
après nous prenons des pois chiches
du cumin du sel et du poivre
aussi pour former une espèce de pâte et
on les laisse goûter
[Musique]
à la fin on mélange l'ensemble avec des
herbes jusqu'à former une belle masse et
on la place dans une poêle avec un peu
d'huile de tournesol pour la frire un
peu d'huile de tournesol pas beaucoup
c'est très important pour notre recette
il faut mettre le feu à haute
température pour obtenir une texture
croquante à l'extérieur et moelleuse à
l'intérieur et voilà on saupoudre un peu
de fromage feta par dessus et puis c'est
prêt pour la dégustation
le Peter Woody c'est l'un des plats les
plus typiques que vous pouvez trouver à
Rhodes
je retrouve à présent Marie Raphaël
minier de la Maison de l'Europe des
Yvelines est responsable du Centre
Europe Direct de Saint-Germain-en-Laye
je voudrais que vous nous en disiez un
petit peu plus sur ce projet JIRA il
s'inscrit dans la continuité du projet
ready qui était consacré avant à la
citoyenneté active en milieu rural
et une fois ce projet clos et approuvé
par l'agence Erasmus on nous a dit mais
pourquoi ne pas aller plus loin vous
avez parlé de la citoyenneté active à
présent on a ces outils formidable qui
est le nouveau pacte vert européen
qu'est-ce qu'on en fait pour dynamiser
les zones rurales donc on a réécrit un
nouveau projet pour 30 mois et quels
sont les objectifs de ce projet
d'un maximum de personnes une boîte à
outils des initiatives qu'on aura vu au
cours de ces 30 mois dans les différents
pays visités c'est à dire que quelqu'un
issu d'une zone rurale en Grèce en Suède
en France ou en Pologne puisse se dire
ça c'est chouette on va essayer de leur
produire et les financements européens
ah oui on peut les obtenir comme ça on a
vu qu'il y avait beaucoup de délégations
si ce total et quels sont les
partenaires de ce projet alors on a la
maison de de bas de Marianne Berg en
Allemagne qui est le coordinateur du
projet la Maison de l'Europe des
Yvelines en France la Fondation Robert
Schuman en Pologne la Maison de l'Europe
de Javier Borg en Suède et la Maison de
l'Europe de Rhodes qu'est-ce que vous
retenez de ce meeting jusqu'à présent à
Rhodes est-ce qu'il y a des initiatives
qui pourraient être pourquoi pas
reprises dans notre région en France oui
tout à fait
même dans des îles par exemple ici à
Rhodes ou jusqu'à présent on avait des
problèmes de pollution de traitement des
déchets etc on voit que les gens même
des générations d'avant ont envie de
changer les choses et je pense notamment
au plastique à la présentation qu'on a
eu du groupe
IGN plastique qui récupère les vieux
masques les bouts de plastique et qui
fait du mobilier urbain de la déco
d'intérieur et je me dis ça je pense
qu'on a le savoir-faire pour le faire et
malheureusement suffisamment déchets en
France pour avoir la matière première
[Musique]
escale à présent sur l'île de chalki
situé à 6 km à l'ouest de Rhodes Lille
vient de lancer un nouveau plan de
transition énergétique
je m'appelle Basilio sorosakis et je
suis le maire adjoint chargé des
questions de croissance économique et
tourisme ici sur l'île de chalki nous
avons présenté en octobre 2010 notre
plan de transition énergétique au
secrétariat européen pour le climat et
l'énergie
d'atteindre nos objectifs et de
respecter notre vision
nous avons mis en place les éléments
nécessaires pour le faire
parmi eux il y a la construction d'un
parc photovoltaïque de 1 mégawatt afin
de couvrir les besoins énergétiques de
l'île comme les logements les
entreprises
[Musique]
nous espérons que la situation se soit
améliorée et que nous aurons réduit nos
émissions de CO2 de 40 à 50 %
c'est très important car il s'agit de
l'avenir nous voulons sauver la planète
et nous avons notre rôle à jouer
et pas seulement sur l'île de shelki
j'espère que tous ceux qui nous écoutent
se rendent compte qu'il faut sauver la
planète pour les générations à venir
l'organisation et la clé pour cela
nous devons tous faire de notre mieux
pour réduire nos émissions de CO2 et
faire de notre planète un endroit plus
agréable et sur à vivre
[Musique]
nous sommes au coeur du Parc Marin
butopia une zone protégée qui bénéficie
de conditions environnementales
exceptionnelles et c'est ici qu'une
ferme à poisson a été installé marine
Nicolas
nous sommes dans une ferme d'aquaculture
que vous voyez dernièrement et qui
s'appelle Lamar
est une entreprise familiale productrice
de poisson de mer de quatre espèces
dentées
soit aussi consommé de manière locale
le marché de Rhodes est riche de ses
poissons pendant toute l'année
pourquoi avons-nous choisi ces poissons
idéal pour produire des protéines de
poissons d'une grande qualité et ce
grasse à l'excellent environnement que
nous avons dans les maires de la Grèce
notamment la mer Égée
en plus la qualité des poissons est
renforcée par la présence des acides
gras oméga-3 de qualité très bénéfique
pour les êtres humains
spécialement intéressante car elle se
situe dans la partie ouest de Rhodes or
comme vous le savez rode est une île
très touristique
et bien dans cette zone nous n'avons
aucune activité touristique
agriculturelle industrielle ou
domestique qui pourrait avoir un impact
sur la qualité des eaux
graphique grâce aux principales
caractéristiques
océanographique de la région et les
magnifiques paysages des îles rocheuses
les eaux sont profondes et les courants
sont forts
sont très heureux ici
[Musique]
nous avons mené une révolution au sein
de cette activité parce que
nous avons réussi dans une île
touristique comme celle-ci à combiné
tourisme et aquaculture
[Musique]
de pouvoir dire que notre travail amène
des visiteurs à découvrir la ferme
d'aquaculture
comprendre le processus d'élevage et de
production
ainsi que leur montrer le niveau de
respect de cet environnement aquatique
comme vous le voyez derrière vous les
visiteurs peuvent ici nager et constater
tout cela par eux-mêmes plutôt que de
manière théorique
autour de la zone pour qu'il puisse voir
la clarté des eaux et les conditions
dans lesquelles grandissent ces poissons
cette zone est protégée les règles de la
ferme ainsi que celle du gouvernement
interdisent la pêche
grâce à cette protection un refuge s'est
créé pour beaucoup de poissons et de
dauphins les dauphins adorent poursuivre
les poissons sans oublier des très
grands tons
résumé ces initiatives pour
l'environnement marin sont ce que les
plongeurs aiment découvrir
la pratique de la plongée dans les zones
proches des cages
et même des dauphins
de chances de rencontrer des dauphins et
bien évidemment une probabilité de 100%
de voir des tons les plongeurs sont
ravis de vivre cette expérience unique
au milieu de la vie marine de saison
[Musique]
zone Europe c'est terminé une émission
spéciale enregistrée à Rhodes en Grèce
très bonne soirée à tous moi je retourne
nager
[Musique]
zone Europe sur sensation
zone Europe avec le soutien financier de
la Région Île-de-France